you got my mind going like i imagine you
back in the day he's sitting at some
table in a comedy club with guys like
chappelle and i could imagine that being
tremendously fun but also
super competitive like oh i gotta i
gotta be witty at this table i gotta be
the smartest guy in the room if i'm
going to keep up with these guys and
earn their respect you know i mean you
hope obviously you're in a business so
you hope you earn people's respect but
like right
even even an idiot could have seen
chappelle coming and been like yeah i'm
not going to try and keep up with that
guy
that's that's a whole different level of
money that i'm just gonna like i'm gonna
admire it i'm gonna enjoy it uh i'm
gonna do my thing and you ever analyze
it do you ever say this guy's so [ __ ]
relaxed and it seems like he's coming up
with material like left and right like
his head how prolific and you go why how
is he doing that what what the hell is
the secret generally i can deconstruct
where somebody's coming from like
you know it's like a magician that goes
to a show once you know the tricks you
can watch it and go like that guy's a
craftsman like that's [ __ ] that's
good craft uh it's really well done but
i know how this i know how this trick
goes
but there are certain people that come
in
and you just go
touched by god that's just that's just
different that's i can't
give you a road map to that
because i'm not sure how he got there
and those are the people that
you tip your cap too you just go
you know i was always somebody that got
by i i i thought i was good but i worked
hard like i had to get better and this
is not to say that brilliant people
don't work hard but there were certain
people where you just go your brain's
different it's kind of a magical thing
i'm glad you're here because i
appreciate it
i love i love watching miles davis as
much as the next guy but i don't know
where that's coming from were you the
type of guy like jerry seinfeld who
would write every day like sit there and
write on a pad every day
no i was more somebody that had to do it
to get better i i wasn't i wasn't good
at the discipline of writing
but i was good at the grind
like i could go out and do like a tell
was like that too like we could grind it
like you know you'd pass each other in
the subway going from standup new york
back down to the cellar back up to
caroline's you know you do your six
shows in a night would you try out new
material on state like one of the things
about chappelle you will go see him on a
night where he might be just kind of
looking around he actually creates on
stage
jerry is said to mean he would never do
that he writes everything out he's all
prepared he he
best craftsman i've ever seen
in this business best
like
he
yeah here's someone that you wouldn't
necessarily think that up but like
seinfeld and carlin have a lot in common
in that they are
very different
but master craftsmen and
it's exactly right [ __ ] prepared they
are so
meticulous that was the thing about
carlin that was so impressive to me and
i was lucky enough to get to know him a
little bit
was his level of preparation
was
second to none
and seinfeld's the only other guy that
i've ever seen that has that same
level of
ability to do that like it's it's
remarkable to me